this is a production of cornell
university
um so thank you everybody for um coming
today to hear me talk about my thesis
work
um and thank you mike for that um
thoroughly embarrassing
uh introduction
um
so uh i wanted to start my talk today by
uh you know doing the acknowledgments
first because uh the work i'm gonna be
sharing today um was really not just my
uh work but the work of a lot of other
people who collaborated with me and
contributed to the research
um so obviously i'd like to thank my
committee members uh mike and adrian um
for being an ed for being super
supportive of me throughout my phd
um i'd also like to thank uh many of the
people who contributed to the research
um that i'll be talking about uh
including josh strabel uh brianne conlon
lucas evans
robin johnson um enrico cohen and jay
chang at the john innes center
as well as the really great people who
work at the cornell
brc who helped with a lot of these
genomic techniques that i use
as well as all the staff at most grade
farm and the cornell greenhouses and
growth chamber facilities who took care
of my plants
during my degree and then i also want to
thank all the members of the scanlan lab
of past and present uh for being uh
really great lab mates and um always uh
being there to have really great
conversations about science and helping
out in the lab and of course my funding
sources as well
um so now the personal part the
sentimental part i guess of the intro so
um it's really no secret to many of the
people here grad school is really hard
um and as mike alluded to there were a
lot of experimental failures i don't
know how many of you are familiar with
seeing a screen like this where all your
sequencing reactions just fail and you
don't know why um so it can be very
demoralizing at times uh when this is
happening and um here's a picture of me
uh completely uh sort of over dramatic
but um i basically just had to lay down
in the lab couch cover myself with a
blanket go to sleep because i just
was
tired of failed experiments um so yeah
grad school is is really difficult but
um you know i couldn't have done it
without all these amazing people
who um i've known either before coming
to cornell or people that i've met here
um
uh family uh friends um these people
really uh kept me sane over the years
um and were super critical to um
uh the research i've done
and i've also um really enjoyed getting
out of ithaca and traveling um that's
also kept me sane um so i've had the
opportunity to travel
quite a bit both on vacation and also
for uh research conferences um and uh
mike has supported a lot of that uh
travel for uh the conference research so
i'm really thankful for that
um and then i also of course have to uh
acknowledge mike
this is a really great picture of my
peering through a
microscope stage
and also mike uh getting the maze
genetics mid-career award and then mike
recently in his corn mask in his office
and
so i really want to
acknowledge mike for being a super
supportive advisor um having faith in me
that i could complete these really
difficult projects
um and allowing me to take a lot of sort
of uh having a lot of scientific freedom
during my phd
allowing me to pursue ideas that are
sometimes really stupid
but
have helped me learn a lot along the way
so thank you to mike
um
and also thank you to corn my model
system for the past five and a half
years of my phd um it can be a really
difficult system to work with um but
it's also been really rewarding and as
you'll see um has
given us a lot of insights into um
developmental biology um so saying
goodbye to corn for now to go work on
tomatoes and tomato relatives but
uh maybe i will come back to corn
someday
okay so um today i'm gonna basically be
telling two um stories uh the first part
of my talk is going to be on previously
published um data uh so um using single
cell transcriptomics to gain a
better insight into the genetic
organization of the maze shoot apical
meristem
and also how cells um differentiate as
they exit the meristem
and then part two of my talk will focus
on uh the uh so instead of the proximate
distal axis of differentiation how
leaves actually grow wide so uh the
using single cell rna-seq to gain
insights into the role of wax iii genes
in uh the development of the leaf margin
and the lingual
and the ligul um might not be of
interest to many of you but
it's going to come up a lot in this talk
so sorry about that
um so
uh to start part one
um
so plants have this uh very uh special
ability to make new organs throughout
their lifespan so um
wondering if i can
how do you make this into a pointer
the mouse
winner options
is that it okay that worked okay cool
got it
so um so in animals um so both plants
and animals undergo
embryogenesis from a fertilized zygote
um but and they set up their body axes
during embryogenesis but in animals the
development of new organs typically ends
after embryogenesis
except in a few rare exceptions like
starfish which can regenerate limbs but
ignoring that
plants are really special in that they
can make new organs throughout their
lifespan owing to the fact that they set
up these populations of pluripotent stem
cells in the shoot apex and the root
apex
that go on to give rise to new organs
throughout the plant's lifespan
and so this isn't just a biological
biological interest it's also really
important um for agriculture and crop
improvement so
um these meristems um are and have been
if you you can tinker with the genes
that control meristem activity for
example branching and you can increase
yields for example shown here in tomato
by modifying the genes that regulate
meristem branching you can increase
tomato yields and you can also
play with the genes that regulate
meristem size and create a inflorescence
meristem that bears more seed
so these uh understanding how mere stems
function is important and relevant for
uh crops as well
so um how do we think about how
meristems are
organized
so um
much of what we know about or how we
think about meristems comes from worked
on an arabidopsis
so um in arabidopsis
the true apical meristem has been
described as having this sort of
canonical organization where you have
stem cells at the tip of the meristem so
these are self-renewing replenishing
stem cells that uh like i said renew
themselves and then also give rise to um
uh differentiating descendants so these
transit amplifying cells that will go on
to contribute to lateral organs
um and the stem cell niche is subtended
by this population of organizing cells
so these cells are um constantly
signaling with and uh regulating the uh
population of uh stem cells um at the
meristem tip
so um today i'll be talking about the
maize um true typical
and um the maze sam is located down at
the base of the vegetative seedling so
uh right down here close to the ground
and it's um surrounded by the uh whirl
of leaves
and on the right here is um a micrograph
showing a longitudinal section of the
shoot apocomeric stem and
you can see that it has compared to
arabidopsis a slightly higher dome to it
but the organization is similar in the
sense that you have putative stem cells
up here at the tip of the sam and their
differentiating descendants go on to
contribute to the stem or colon tissue
as well as the lateral organs so these
lateral organs are then
named or identified based on how
recently they've initiated from the sam
so p1 for plasticron 1 or the first
initiated leaf and then p2 for the
second most recently initiated leaf here
on the right
so um i'll also be talking a lot today
about the morphology of the maize leaf
or the grass leaf so
unlike in arabidopsis maize has a
sheathing leaf base that we think is
homologous to the petiole and
arabidopsis
and the uh so the the sheath is a
proximal structure that wraps around the
stem and stabilizes the uh the chute
and the blade then um is a distal
structure that is angled away from the
plant owing to the um
presence of an oracle tissue down here
that sort of acts as a hinge
and this oracle region and this blade
sheath boundary is associated with this
fringe of epidermal tissue that we call
the ligul
and so you can see this uh here in this
real image
of the blade sheath boundary
so um we are interested in using the
single cell uh transcriptomic technology
to um better understand um how the maze
two typical meristem is organized
genetically um and how similar is this
the meristem and maze with arabidopsis
there are a lot of gaps that we don't um
fully understand in terms of comparing
these uh diverged meristem types
uh we're also interested in how
gene expression dynamic dynamics change
um over the course of cell
differentiation so how does the cell go
from being a stem cell to being a
differentiated lateral organ and then
we're also interested in how that
process is regulated so what can we
learn about the genes that actually
control this
developmental process
so um as mike uh described in the intro
um it turned out to be pretty difficult
to isolate
cell individual cells from the the shoot
apocalypse stand so um it's a very small
tissue so there's not a lot of it and
also the cells seem to not really like
being taken out of their um their niche
in the meristem
so um i
ended up
harvesting um
these meristems and the two most
recently initiated leaf primordia
and um using uh enzymatic digestion of
the cell walls to isolate individual
cells
and then i labeled these cells with a
viability marker um to make sure we're
picking healthy living protoplasts
and um i then washed these cells and
used a technique called cell c2 to
generate these single cell rna-seq
libraries from this targeted tissue type
and so um this is sort of what uh the
visualization of the data looks like so
on the right here is a umap plot um so
this is a dimensionality reduction
technique that we can use to visualize
really high dimensional data in a
sort of a latent space
and um each of these uh
dots represents a cell
and they are colored based on a
hierarchical clustering um which we um
then
assigned cell type putative cell type
identities to based on the
marker genes that we see expressed in
those different cell types or clusters
so um we were first really interested in
what what's actually happening in the
tip of the meristem so this is where the
putative stem cells are
and so um one of the best uh
transcriptional markers we have for this
uh tip domain
uh where the stem cells reside um is
this gene called dynamin so um on the
left here is a micrograph showing a
longitudinal section of the meristem and
where the staining is is where uh
transcripts of this dynamic gene are
accumulating
and so when we look in the gene
expression or the single cell data we
see that there's a population of cells
with a high degree of transcriptional
similarity expressing dynamic that are
clustering together in our data set
suggesting that we've captured cells
from this tip population
and these reside within a broader
population of cells that are expressing
knotted one which is a class one
homeobox gene that promotes um
indeterminate
cell identity and proliferation
so what are these what can we learn
about what these stem cells are doing um
so we can use
um differential gene expression to
identify uh which genes are upregulated
in these dynamic or tip
cells
and what's really interesting is that we
found many genes that appear to be
involved in genome integrity maintenance
so
dna repair related genes were
upregulated as well as genes that are
involved in the rna-directed dna
methylation pathway which helps silence
transposable elements
it was also interesting to note that
several genes that we identified have
been previously associated with germ
cell development
so reproductive development which was
quite surprising given that these are
vegetative meristems that haven't yet
transitioned to flowering
so this all suggested that perhaps these
stem cells are maintaining the fidelity
of the genome as they're going to be
responsible for giving rise to all of
this the many of the cells in the plant
the above ground portion of the plant as
well as eventually the germline
so um
one that's one way of ensuring genomic
fidelity by uh making sure that the dna
uh remains um very uh
that th that the dna is protected but
another mechanism to do that is also by
regulating cell division so each time a
cell divides uh the dna has to be
replicated and that replication process
can introduce errors and so another
mechanism by which these stem cells
could
protect themselves from dna damage is by
having a very slow rate of cell division
and so what we did is looked at the cell
division rates um in the uh or the
the
cell
cycle stages of all the cells in this
data set and we could bend them into
different
stages so we have g1 s phase and g2 m
phase cells labeled here
um and what we found is that cells that
uh if that come from the tip of the
meristem tend to have the lowest traits
of cells actively
in the g2m phase of the cell cycle
whereas the rates or the numbers of
cells that we captured in the active
process of dividing were much higher in
um other tissues in the shoot apex
and we went in and invalidated this
using nc2 hybridization so we looked at
some of these markers of the cell cycle
such as this histone h3 gene for the s
phase and cyclin 1 for g2m phase and
what we found when we bend the meristem
in the apical to basal direction is that
the the proportion of cells actively
cycling um is lowest at the tip of the
meristem consistent with what we're
seeing in the single cell rna-seq data
so taken together this suggests that
plants might employ two different
mechanisms in their stem cells to ensure
that they've reduced the accumulation of
somatic mutations as much as possible in
those cells that won't just be
contributing to
somatic tissues but also to reproductive
tissues as plants need to grow to
reproduce and so this might explain how
even very long-lived plants like this
methuselah tree in california
which is over 4 500 years old might
still be able to
produce viable gametes and not fall prey
to mutational breakdown over so many
successive cell divisions
so um
we were also interested in understanding
how uh the meristem organization
compares to arabidopsis
and so um one of the key pathways that
um has been described in arabidopsis for
regulating the meristem is the clavada
wishel signaling pathway
um i'm sure many of you have heard about
this before
but um just briefly um uh what how it's
understood is that bushel is a homeobox
transcription factor which promotes stem
cell identity um it's also mobile so
it's expressed in the organizing center
of the shoot apical meristem it then
moves apically where it uh
into the stem cell population where it
activates stem cell identity as well as
expression of clavata3
which is a small secreted peptide that
signals through clavata1 leucine-rich
receptor-like kinases um in then
inhibits wishful expression so this this
forms a negative feedback loop that
maintains meristem size keeps it from
getting too big or too small
so um looking in the single cell data we
were able to identify um
potential candidates for uh the clea
gene clavada3 uh this gene called fcp1
which has been shown to be involved in
meristem size regulation
we also found numerous genes that um are
clavada1 like some of these have also
been characterized as being important
for meristem homeostasis but what was uh
really uh surprising to us was that we
couldn't identify a bushel candidate
gene so a whistle seemed to be missing
from the dataset
and so we did rtpcr to see if we could
detect it that way and while we could
detect the expression of zm uh wishel
one and two in the ear primordium uh we
could not detect it in the shoot
applicable meristem
and this is also consistent with laser
capture microdissection and rna-seq
studies of the meristem where uh there's
been no candidate bushel gene identified
in the the maze vegetative sam
so um
perhaps we just missed the organizing
center perhaps we just didn't digest
cells at the core of the meristem where
we expect wishful to be
so um there's been a previously
published marker gene of unknown
function
um in this nc2 hybridization you can see
it's expressed in the the center of the
sam where we might expect the organizing
center to be
and we do detect expression of this of
this gene in the single cell rna-seq
data so it does seem that we're
detecting cells from the core of the
meristem
but what's surprising is again we don't
really see any of those signatures of an
organizer like you see in arabidopsis
except for one gene which we found a
grass 33 gene that um has been
characterized as having rules in
meristem regulation in
arabidopsis and appears to be expressed
in the more basal part of the shooter
become meristem
and developing leaves
so how does this gene regulate
meristem homeostasis
so in arabidopsis
these genes
are called the perimeter stem hairy
meristem genes and so um these gene
these genes uh encode products protein
products that interact with and phys and
uh inhibit whistle from activating stem
cell identity outside of the tip of the
meristem
so it was curious to see that these
genes are still being expressed in the
maze sam uh but we are not able to
identify bushel so what are they doing
do they have a function of meristem
maintenance in in maze
so um we isolated um mutator insertion
lines for um grass 33 as well as another
um homolog grass 32 and what we found is
that um in the double mutants as well as
the grass 33 grass 32 heads there was a
small but significant reduction in the
size of the shield meristem so this
suggests that potentially these grass
genes in maize um have a wish
independent regulatory function an issue
typical meristem
which is
quite surprising
so if there's no bushel um how is this
thing
maintaining itself how is this working
um i think there's some interesting
precedence for neurostems that
can function in the absence of uh
wishful
so in uh moss albeit in the mosque
amidophyte um
you have an active clavada one uh
signaling pathway but there's no wishful
function in the gametophyte
but to be fair this isn't really a
multicellular sound it's a single apical
cell but i also think there's some
interesting um
factors or aspects about the bushel
immune phenotype even in arabidopsis
that indicate that you might still be
able to have a
functional meristem i'll be a slightly
disruptive one that produces these
aerial rosettes
but you might still be able to have a
functional meristem even in the absence
of wishel so it's possible that uh just
because you don't have wishful doesn't
mean you don't have a
functional sam
so um as i said at the beginning we're
also really interested in using this
technology to
uh understand how cells undergo
differentiation so how do you go from a
stem cell to a leaf primordial cell or a
vasculature cell
and so uh by taking these single cell uh
transcriptome profiles we're able to
basically capture a static snapshot of
cells at differing stages of cell
differentiation
so um
basically what you can do here is fit a
graph to the latent space of these cells
and then assign each cell a pseudo time
value which is sort of an abstract um
concept of developmental time to each
cell based on its position along this
trajectory and so we can follow this
trajectory from the stem cells
out to the leaf primordia and the
epidermis and vasculature
and so
we can follow the expression of genes
along this trajectory so for example
knotted one the
meristem uh identity and indeterminacy
regulator you see that early in
pseudotime its expression is high and as
pseudotime progresses its expression
drops as cells undergo differentiation
so um we're able to basically take this
data and um identify genes that show
expression correlations with um this
pseudotime progression and so we can
find different modules of genes that
are regulated at different times
in the trajectory so you have cells that
are um or genes that are upregulated in
the tip
shutting off and you can follow these
cells as they move along these branches
in the trajectory and we've looked at
some of these within c2 hybridization
to figure out where these genes are
coming on so genes that appear to be
involved in
or coming up in lateral organs seem to
be
expressed there
um genes involved in the epidermis seems
to be uh coming up at the the epidermal
margins of the leaves
and also genes that appear early in the
trajectory are coming up in the the
meristem
so this uh first uh data set this sam
plus p2 data set as we're calling it
was a pretty small cell sample we only
captured like 320 something cells
so we also wanted to um sort of validate
the uh results of that with a larger
cell subset
um so we took tissue from the street
apical meristem and the six most
recently initiated leaf primordia
and used um microfluidic droplet capture
using the 10x genomics chromium platform
to survey a much larger population of
cells from the shoot apex
and so we weren't able to identify cells
from the meristem in this
cell population
hence the necessity of manually picking
cells which was really quite tedious but
the good news was that we were able to
actually identify a similar
developmental transition um of cells in
this data set so we could follow brown
tissue cells as they go from an
indeterminate
uh sulfate through uh boundary regions
and then in on into a more determinate
cell identities in the in the leaves and
so we can look at the expression of
genes that mark this pathway so going
from cells expressing not at one
through cells expressing cup two in the
boundaries and then on to yabby 15
determined to see mercury in the leaves
okay so we've now observed all these
patterns of
gene expression uh what can we learn
about how this uh process of cell
differentiation is actually regulated
so um we have these two data sets i
really indicated that um not possible
and nox genes specifically not at one
gene expression patterns are very
specific for these indeterminate cell
fates and we've also learned through
several decades of research into class 1
nox gene function that these are really
important regulators of growth and
indeterminacy as well as being important
for meristem regulation
um and a lot of really nice work has
come out of studying dominant mutations
in these class one oxygens so in tomato
if you over express knotted one or the
not in one ortholog you get this super
compound leaf so by um basically putting
this indeterminacy program in the leaf
you're able to turn that
already compound leaf into this super
compound crazy looking tomato leaf
um
in maize the phenotype is a bit
different when you over express knotted
one in leaves
you don't get a super compound leaf but
rather you get these proliferative knots
of tissue out in the blade hence the
name of the phenotype knotted one
and when you lose function of this gene
um depending on the uh background in
maize um the genetic background you get
a shoe termination phenotype so um the
seedlings maybe make a few leaves and
then the meristem shuts down and the
plant basically ceases all growth
so um
we are interested to understand exactly
what not it is doing when it's
ectopically expressed in
differentiating leaf cells
is it slowing down development
um what's what's its what's its function
there are we getting um ectopic
meristems in the leaves um how is this
working and so um
we took uh cells from wild-type um
siblings and nodded one oh dominant
mutants so these are over expressing
knotted and leaves
and we perform single cell rna-seq and
we're able to generate a trajectory of
cells again stretching across that
indeterminate to determine an
identity transition
and um we found that indeed in knotted
one over expressing plants you get
higher levels of expression of knotted
one in the um the differentiating uh
leaf cells
and uh so we get transcripts there but
is this protein actually functioning
there and so um it's been known through
chipseek studies that knotted one
directly binds and modulates the
activity of uh ga
two oxidase gene which is involved in
catabolism
and so we see that in these knotted one
plants we're getting um
upregulation of this direct target as
well in the leaves suggesting that the
knotted protein is actually modulating
gene expression in these cells
so um what's happening with pseudotime
what's the effect of knotted one on cell
differentiation and this was a really
big surprise to us i hypothesized that
knotted one would basically slow down
cell differentiation by introducing an
indeterminate cell identity in leaves
what we actually found is that knotted
one slightly um increases the pseudotime
status of uh the cells from the nautical
mutant
so um this was kind of a head scratcher
for a bit
and uh we were talking quite a lot
wrong side
so um
we found that um knotted one cells are
actually expressing genes that we
associate more with
determinacy than indeterminacy so we
specifically looked in cells where
ga2ox1 expression is upregulated so
suggesting that not if one protein is
active and what we found is that um
cells uh those cells um are expressing
higher levels of not at one but also
determinancy markers like drooping leaf
one and yabby 15. so both of these are
yabby genes that we know are expressed
in leaves
and um likewise we see that these there
are several of these lsh
light-sensitive hypocotyl genes that we
also know are expressed in the in the
basis of leaves so it seems like these
cells that are ectopically responding to
naughty one actually might have enhanced
determinacy
um and are not reverting back to a
meristematic fate
so um
now this is where i was going to say so
uh we were talking about this result
and um i was talking with josh strabel
um who's a former postdoc in the lab
he's now a professor at north carolina
state
um and he had been working on um the
role of knotted one in specifying uh
potentially specifying the control of
the blade sheath boundary uh formation
early on during leaf on top gene and so
he had been measuring the length of the
sheath relative to the blade um in uh
knotted one dominant mutants
and what he found was that in these
mutants the sheath length so the the
sheaving leaf base uh of the maize leaf
was actually elongated relative to the
blade in the knotted one uh mutants and
so this was suggesting that this ectopic
activity of knotted one was actually
promoted sheath identity where it's
normally supposed to be
and in addition uh josh showed really
nicely through a genetic interaction
analysis
that
these patches of uh proliferative tissue
in the blade that you get in the knotted
one o dominant mutant um are coupled
with um little ectopic patches of ligul
and that these ectopic patches of
presumptive ligul are actually sensitive
to loss of function of the ligulous one
gene which is required for normal
regular development
so what we think is happening is that
knotted one is promoting sheath identity
and so it might have a role in actually
promoting cell differentiation via this
mechanism of uh promoting sheath
identity and so how might this work and
sort of sync up with the single cell
rna-seq results
so um during the ontogeny or the
development of the maze leaf what
emerges first
in wild type development is the blade
and as development progresses you get
elongation of the leaf and then you
start to get initiating initiation of
sheath at the leaf base and so what we
think is happening in knotted one is
that you're either getting potentially
earlier initiation of sheath but
certainly at later stages there's more
sheath present and you also have these
ectopic patches of sheath identity so we
think that knotted one is actually
involved in advancing the um
uh ontogeny of leaf development through
its impact in promoting uh sheath
sulfate
so in a wild type plant how might
knotted one actually promote sheath
development um it's not the messenger
rna does not accumulate in leaves but it
seems like the protein might
so um this on the left is an rna and c2
hybridization you can see nodded one in
the meristem and the calm
but the protein seems to have some
mobility so
as leaf ontogeny progresses you see this
progressive increase in the amount of
knotted one protein detected by
immunologization in the leaves so
potentially this uh sheath specification
function um is due to the mobility of
the knotted one transcription factor
into into leaves
okay
so um
like i said there will be there um
there's a part two of the talks um and
so uh the first part was published um
and this part is uh new stuff that um i
think is really exciting um looking at
uh the role of walks three in the
development of maize leaves and also
that little mysterious
fringe of legal tissue
um so
back in the 90s
there was a lot of work to identify the
genes that are involved in regulating
different aspects of leaf patterning and
development so i talked about knotted
and but there was also an interest in
how not just leaves pattern themselves
along the approximate distal axis but
actually how they grow wide
and so mike during his uh postdoc in
mike freeling's lab um characterized uh
this two-factor trait called uh narrow
sheath that um conditions a narrow leaf
phenotype and so in these uh neurosheath
mutants
you have a reduction in the in the width
of the leaf and so um it's really
pronounced in the sheath and you can see
the sheath pulling away from the the
shoot axis because it can't fully wrap
itself around
um
the chute and you can see down here that
the leaves are are narrower
and if you look at a um cross section of
the maize the mage shoot apex so this is
a transverse section
um you got the sam here in the middle
and then um in normal siblings of uh
narrative you have um these really nice
tapered leaf margins
that are growing outwards to wrap around
the uh the street apex but in narrow
sheath the
leaves fail to fully wrap around the
shoot apex and you get these blunted
margins where growth has ceased
prematurely
so um mike went on to clone neuroshift
so as i said it's a two factor trait so
there's neuroshift one and narrow sheath
2. you need both of these mutated to
have a mutant phenotype
and they encoded walks 3 transcription
factors so same family as wishel these
are homeybox transcription factors
and they have this really beautiful
expression pattern in just a few cells
in a leaf margin
um so this is a transverse section
showing activity at the growing tips of
the leaves
and um in some cases it literally looks
like it's just one cell like it's crazy
um
so uh narrative wasn't the only mutant
that was characterized at the time that
has a narrow leaf phenotype um others
were working to understand how
um this mediolateral growth takes place
and um a study about weights and hudson
in 1995 characterized mutant called
fantastica
and antarinum and these mutants um
failed to completely fail to produce a
lamina so in the fantastica mutants the
leaf is basically reduced to this little
tiny
strip of tissue
that's presumably just the mid-rib
and what they found is that when they
looked at the cells
actually in this little narrow leaf they
found that they had all the cells on the
outer part of the leaf and also the
vasculature inside had become completely
radialized so you had the conversion of
what would typically be add axial cells
to completely ad-axial cells shown in
this like very simple ball diagram here
um so
these authors
propose this idea that you need
juxtaposition of adaxion abaxial cell
identities to create a wide leaf
and after a lot of molecular genetic
studies to understand the roles
and clone the actual genes that are
involved in setting up this patterning
it's been found that there's this sort
of mutually antagonistic
interaction between transcription
factors micrornas
that control this add and add patterning
and what's interesting is that walks
three genes appear to be at this sort of
uh juxtaposition between these two
domains so wherever you have this this
um these adjacent add and add uh uh
expression domains you tend to get watch
three expression and then mediolateral
leaf outgrowth
so um we were interested
in better understanding how this
margin region is organized
is it similar to ameristem is
what exactly is happening there uh where
walks three genes are being expressed in
just those few little cells
so um we sample tissue from um
the sam plus p6
sort of tissue cassette again
and we isolated protoplasts from that
tissue
from both the normal um siblings and
their the neuroscience mutants
uh performed a single cell rna-seq using
the 10x chromium
platform and we captured about 17 000
cells
into replicates
and so we can um again uh use uh
dimensionality reduction to look at this
data and we can assign
cell types to the different
cell populations based on the genes
they're expressing
and so um we did identify what is the
putative wax iii expression domain so a
small population of the epidermis
appears to be where um
this
uh margin patterning program is active
and so um again this is just showing um
we can
find these walks three genes in this
subpopulation of the epidermis so we
have epidermal markers like ocl4
and ltp2 that really light up these
epidermal clusters and what we see is
that narrow sheath one and two are being
expressed in just a few cells in that
population and um i should also mention
that there are two uh duplicate paralogs
of narrative one and two wax 3a and
watch 3b and they also appear to be
co-expressed there
so um
like i said we're interested in
transcriptionally characterizing the
signatures of this
margin domain
and we can do that by looking at the
differentially expressed genes um that
uh are specific specifically mark uh the
uh the margins in the plant that are in
these in these cells that are expressing
these wax three genes
and we can use in c2 hybridization to
look at their localization so this is
just a subset of markers that we
identified and you can see that they are
expressed to varying degrees in the leaf
margins
um so
now that we have all this data this
characterization of the margin what's
happening in airship we would assume
that neurosheet's role is to maintain
this
this marginal organizer or this
marginal transcriptional state
and so we looked at the cells
in compared cells between the mutants
and the normal siblings
and look to see which transcriptional
states are most likely to be perturbed
and so um you can see that um in in
looking at this human clot there are
many of these cells that are called as
being depleted so these are
transcriptional states that you would
expect to see less likely in the
narrative mutant so we see a lot of
these um depleted cell states
and that's consistent with what we know
about the narration phenotype it sort of
deletes
a portion of the
of the leaf so we see both epidermal and
ground tissue mesophyll cells um kind of
going missing or being less likely to be
found in the narrative mutant
but when we looked at the actual
cells in the walks three domain we only
found a very modest reduction or
depletion of these
marginal cells in neurosheath and so
this was really confusing
because neuroscience presumably has a
marginal program that's been shut off
prematurely but we're only seeing this
very small
effect on the margin identity cell type
so um we were scratching our heads at
this and um it really took going into
that gene list
to figure out what might be going on
here
so um the um
in the in this list of differentially
expressed genes we found um
this gene called libidos one which i was
mentioning a little bit earlier
and liculus 1 is expressed specifically
in the developing liguels
but it hasn't been characterized or seen
ever before in leaf margins there's no
support for it really being there
and indeed when we look at its
expression the umap plot we see a few
cells expressing nucleus one and that
margin population as well as some um
other places like the mesophyll here
um
and so um this was really surprising to
us
and god is thinking that perhaps the
marginal
cells that we've identified here aren't
just coming from the leaf margins but
also might be coming from a margin
that's present in the ligul
um so the liguel might be using the same
genetic program as the margin to
develop and grow out
um and so we we compared the uh overall
transcriptomes of cells coming from the
leaf margin in this single cell study
with previously um published laser
capture rna-seq data sets from uh the
leaf margin um as well as the ligal
epidermis and what we found is that
there's a highly significant
overlap in the genes differentially
expressed in all three of these data
sets suggesting that perhaps both the
ligul the developing ligul and the
developing margin are using the same
molecular program to
grow
so this could in part explain why in
airship plants which still retain a
normal ligul we're still seeing a lot of
cells with this margin cell type
identity
but um there's another possibility too
and that was that
uh we have these two duplicate parallels
of narrow sheath one and two in uh uh in
maze so we have blocks three a and locks
three b
so could these also be
helping to retain some level of margin
identity in
these plants
and so um brienne conlon who was a
former lab tech in the lab who's now
gone on to work at inari
was working with iowa state to generate
these uh crispr cass uh nine knockouts
of both wax 3a and wax 3b and maze
and so she generated alleles that
result in frame shift mutations that
the peptide sequence and introduce
premature stop codons so these are
putative null wheels that she generated
and she started by making watch 3a walks
through the double moves to see if um
perhaps these have any phenotype on
their own and it turns out they don't
which was quite surprising and a little
scary and disappointing i think but um
what she then did is she set up um a uh
process to make uh quadruple mutants
between neurosheet 1 nerishit ii watch
3a and walks 3b so looking for a 1 in
256 expected segregation ratio for maybe
a more extreme phenotype
and so um these have just recently been
planted out
and uh
lucas evans has been helping with
genotyping of these plants
and um
what we found is that these uh plants
this really extreme narrowly phenotype
in this really disorganized shoot
phenotype appears to actually segregate
at a ratio we would expect for a three
factor trait
um so these plants have really really
narrow leaves and they make really
disorganized shoots and you can see here
these are narrow sheath one two wax 3a
triple mutants
and this is a narrative 1 2 wax 3ab quad
mutant and they don't really look uh
that different
so we think that wax 3b might be
dispensable for this really severe
phenotype whereas uh wax 3a
neuroscientist 2 likely have some level
of genetic redundancy with each other
um so we've really perturbed the margins
of the leaves what about the ligul which
we think also might be a margin
or have a marginal
developmental program
so we looked at the mar the ligul's in
these mutants um so on the left is a
normal um seedling leaf and you can see
it has a nice um blade sheath boundary
with the liguel forming here
neurosheath one in two means you've lost
the the sheathing uh margin of the leaf
but you still have more or less normal
ligul
but what we see in these um higher order
walks three mutants is that the ligul is
uh very severely perturbed sometimes um
you have only a partial libule forming
um other times it seems to be displaced
proxima distally
and other times it's sort of it it forms
a foligule but it's not um it's not
especially long
so um we think that this these
three mutants are also affecting the
development of the liguel consistent
with what we see molecularly
and um
some of these plants even don't appear
to produce a blade sheet foundry at all
so there doesn't appear to be any um
blade sheath boundary there's no ligul
or oracle
and they just look like kind of
spaghetti noodles
so
um
as i was talking about earlier um we
have to come back to this idea of what's
upstream of walks three what's
regulating it and controlling its
expression
so as i said you have
in this model proposed by weights and
hudson you have wax 3 function
downstream of this juxtaposed these
juxtaposed domains that add axial and ad
axial
cell identity
and so we next wondered okay so wax 3
appears to be functioning in the um the
developing liguel is there an ad ab help
polarity
in that developing ligal tissue
so um
we used in-situ hybridization to um look
for canonical markers of adaxial and
have axial cell identity as well as
wax iii expression so we were able to
detect
a little expression of r3 in the
developing liguel
um and this is an ab axial marker so you
can see it marks the ad axial side of
these
initiating leaves um and this this gene
has been characterized in arabidopsis to
be important for um axial cell identity
we also can detect narrow sheath one and
two expression um in the developing
legule and we can also detect expression
of how uh maize fabulosa which is an ad
axial patterning factor and marks the ad
axial report portion of initiating
leaves as well as the ad axial
vasculature
so this in situ data seems to suggest
that there's a
juxtaposed domains of ad and ad polarity
as well as narrative box 3 function in
the ligue
so we also wanted to go in and more
quantitatively um assess the identities
of these cells in the developing libya
and so um i took advantage of some data
published by maya timmermans
who sampled using laser capture micro
dissection rna-seq the add-axial and
ad-axial sides of the
p2 leaf primordium
and so i use this
technique called the index of cell
identity
developed by donna ferroni to basically
get a quantitative readout of
cell identity either add ab or mixed
identity based on the
marker genes from this rna-seq data are
present in these cells
and so we can use this to basically
assign cells um a putative um uh
uh identity is either add ab or or mixed
and um we can look at all cells in the
data set here
um at their breakdown of
sort of their polarity
identity
what's intriguing is that what cells in
the watts three domains seem to have a
majority add axial identity um or mixed
identity but most importantly these
cells that are expressing lobulus one so
coming from that developing libyal
appear to have both add and app identity
as well as um this sort of mixed
identity suggesting that um this single
cell data is um sort of recapitulating
what we saw with the in c2s that the
ligue has these juxtaposed ad and
domains
so
could these add and add domains in the
context of the liguel actually be
sufficient to
to
help it grow out and define that blade
sheet boundary so um
enrico colin and his student jay chang
have been developing finite element
models to study uh leaf uh morphogenesis
in both dicots and udot or monocots
um so they've just uh they're about a
study they've done on the maze uh
leaf um compared to the arabidopsis leaf
is about to come out in science
um and so they've been developing these
these models to better understand how
growth is regulated and uh forms these
uh differences in leaf morphology
and so they had been trying to model the
blade sheath boundary um
for a while and um they generated this
uh they made this finite element model
to to do that
and so um basically they have a uh this
is basically the starting state of the
model and they've assigned different
portions of this tissue different um uh
uh regionalization so you have a blade
tissue
more distally oracle tissue
adjacent to the ligul and red and then
sheathing tissue at the base
and this is just a cross-sectional view
of the leaf and the identity states
and there's also this boundary region so
this growth regression zone
just distal to the um the ligal that
they've included
and so these domains tell the model how
fast or what the growth rate is of each
of these domains
and then they've also specified using
polarity fields which direction the the
growth will occur in so
they have a
proximity distal growth field so
orienting growth distally
and then also this field gets reoriented
around the developing liguel
and then in the um this ortho planar
polarity field they've included these
add axial and ab axial
uh
fields that they use basically to
pattern the margin of the maize leaf in
their full leaf model
and so the question was then okay is
this sufficient to create
a
elaborated liguel
and so
is this going to play
okay
that's not working right
okay so
basically um the
model they generated
um does successfully produce a ligul so
um you start out with the uh the
starting state of the model and then as
development progresses they've they've
included a basically a gradient of
growth in the oracle uh to get it to
basically grow out like a hinge so the
cells grow at the margin or growing
faster than cells at the mid-rib
and then as this progresses you get this
outgrowth of the ligul and this
hinge-like structure of the blade sheath
boundary
so um this all makes us think that
perhaps what's happening in the liguel
is very similar to what's happening in
initiating leaf primordia with
juxtaposed domains of add-axial and
ad-axial identity um uh betwixt which um
there's a walk-three expression at the
the growing tip
um so
what is the ligul um
and i think um i'm going i kind of think
that it might be a leaflet um so uh
the there's been a lot of work done in
arabidopsis and in a close relative
cardamomy hirsuta
um by miltosientis um studying um what
genes or factors are necessary to make a
compound leaf with leaflets
and so it turns out um you just need um
auxin um at these uh marginal um uh
protrusions
um
expression in the sinuses
and then uh to get in this in
arabidopsis is sufficient to make um
little leaf serrations but then when you
introduce the function of these um class
1 nox genes
which are coming up again
rco and stm you're able to uh make this
deeply uh these leaves with deep sinuses
that go on to produce leaflets
and so do we see similar
molecular genetic signatures in maize
so um at the liguel so
previous work has shown that pin one gfp
accumulates the protein accumulates in
cells at the
preligal band so we have this polar
auxin transport that's presumably
allowing oxygen to accumulate
where the ligue will develop
we have we see expression of class 1 nox
genes so this gene ligulus 3 appears to
accumulate
where the ligul is emerging and then we
also have boundary gene function uh
based on expression of the ortholog of
[ __ ] and nase and now what i've shown
you today we seem to also have walks
three function as well as add an ab
polarity at the developing liguel so
my
big hypothesis or idea for all this is
that maybe the maize leaf has some
degree of compoundness and we're seeing
that expressed in the developing liguel
that's pretty
yeah maybe a little controversial but
i think that the ligul is using the
leaflet program to develop
okay
so thank you everybody for coming today
and i will be happy to answer your
i have a question in questions second
part so do using similar type of changes
you can add an ad uh
like
yeah um that's a great question um as
far as i know in the mature legule i i'm
not aware of any
one looking at the ad versus ab like
cell type identity there but that would
be a really interesting thing to do to
see if yeah the
axial versus ab axial sides of the uh
the ligul um have any morphological
differences just like a leaf does
yeah
yeah truss so you spoke to the
similarity between the ligal and the
leaf
programs if you look at the genes that
are differentially expressed do they
tell you anything about the function of
the video
so um yeah good question so uh i should
be repeating the question for the people
in zoom sorry about that so joss's
question was do we see any genes that
are maybe unique to the liguel versus a
margin that could
tell us something about the ligual
function um so far i haven't really
looked into that um that's a great
question though because we don't
actually know what the ligul does um
it's some people hypothesize it prevents
pathogens and water from getting down
into the world of the
uh plant but um
no one's really tested that um and it
seems to be actually pretty
metabolically active in on some other
monocot species so it seems to be
potentially secreting producing these
secretory vesicles that we don't really
know what they're doing but they're
there yeah
yes
so i'm going to go back to the first
part of the talk and
ask you a little bit about
transcription stochasticity so yeah
in
the sort of temp
cell population and you're using this
dynamite
only a subpopulation of those cells are
actually expressing that cheap
and and so i'm wondering is
is there um
i assume you see this a lot in single
cell
in general
but i'm wondering if if
the meristems
back stem cell population is more or
less noisy than more differentiated
cells
okay so yeah the question is
is the transcriptional noise burstiness
greater in the tip of the meristem than
other cell types
um so um
we haven't looked at that and that was
actually something we were quite
interested in was understanding gene
expression stochasticity in different
cell types in the in the meristem
the problem though that we found out is
that there's so much technical noise in
single cell rna-seq so you have a lot of
dropouts of expression most expression
values are actually zero in these
matrices of gene expression by by cells
so
um it's it's very difficult to
distinguish between technical noise and
the actual biological noise
um so i kind of avoided
exploring that um but
i think as these technologies get better
and more sensitive it'll hopefully be
possible to start asking some of those
questions
um yeah
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu